la Cour pénale internationale a émis un
mandat d'arrêt contre le président russe
Vladimir Poutine c'est en lien avec la
déportation d'enfants Ukrainiens vers la
Russie je vais en parler avec Tamara
Alteresco parce que Tamara en plus il y
a un autre mandat aussi lancé qui cette
fois contre la commissaire
présidentielle au droit de l'enfant en
Russie oui mariage lova beauva qu'on
connaît pas beaucoup mais qui est un
poste très important au sein du Kremlin
et bon on parle d'un jugement d'une
décision historique aujourd'hui parce
que c'est seulement la deuxième fois
depuis la création du Tribunal pénal
international qu'on émet un mandat
d'arrestation contre un président qui
est en fonction et oui on s'attendait
parce qu'on savait que la Cour enquêtait
sur des possibles crimes de guerre en
Ukraine mais peut-être pas aussitôt
qu'on s'attaque vraiment à la tête à la
de la hiérarchie politique en Russie
donc ce que la Cour Pénale nous dit
aujourd'hui c'est que Vladimir Poutine
et sa commissaire au droit des enfants
sont des complices de crimes de guerre
on les accuse carrément d'être
personnellement responsable pour ce que
la Cour appelle son langage légal le
transfert ou la déportation illégale
d'enfants on dit d'individus mais
spécifiquement de centaines d'enfants
depuis des territoires
Ukrainiens occupés par la Russie vers la
Fédération russement d'autres mots ceux
dont on accuse de Vladimir Poutine et sa
commissaire au droit des enfants c'est
carrément d'enlèvement et vous savez on
a vu beaucoup et je pense que vous avez
ces images-là de la commissaire
elle-même qui dit avoir elle-même adopté
un enfant de Mario Paul après l'invasion
de la ville par les troupes russes on
l'a vu aussi
se promener et accueillir des enfants
qu'on faisait venir depuis des
orphelinats par exemple de donuts vers
Moscou donc la Russie c'est jamais caché
de d'amener des enfants Ukrainiens mais
il a toujours dit a toujours dit qu'elle
le faisait sous le couvert d'une mission
humanitaire autrement dit ce que la
Russie nous dit aujourd'hui c'est que
c'est de la foutaise ses accusations-là
ce qu'on fait depuis le début avec ses
enfants là c'est qu'on les sauve mais
dans les faits ça veut dire quoi cette
accusation là pour Monsieur Poutine mais
c'est pas symbolique parce que c'est
c'est quand même pas anodin c'est un
tribunal pénal international mais qui
est pas reconnu par l'ensemble de la
planète et qui n'a pas de pouvoir
d'arrestation c'est à dire qu'il le dit
le juge qui en a fait l'annonce
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est mandat
d'arrestation là c'est que la capacité
de mettre la main au collet des gens qui
sont qui sont recherchés qui sont des
fugitifs parce que c'est ça Julie que
Poutine devient aujourd'hui un fugitif
de la Cour pénale internationale
il va pouvoir vivre en toute impunité
tant et aussi longtemps c'est sûr qu'il
reste en Russie ou qui n'est pas
signataire et ne reconnaît pas la
juridiction comme l'Ukraine ne la
reconnaît pas la juridiction de la Cour
pénale internationale ni les États-Unis
donc on compte vraiment sur des pays
pour aider pour coopérer donc ça
pourrait limiter les déplacements de la
lumière poutine au fil des mois au fil
des ans dans des pays qui sont peut-être
oui alliés encore à la Russie mais qui
sont signataires du traité qui a mis sur
pied cette Cour Pénale intern nationale
mais ça pourrait effectivement prendre
des semaines des mois peut-être jamais
mener à des accusations formelles et un
procès mais ce qu'on nous dit
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on est en train de
monter très sérieusement un dossier pour
crime de guerre et ça c'est le début on
a entendu Joseph Borel aujourd'hui le
chef de la diplomatie européenne dire on
assiste au début d'une enquête parce que
ce qui se passe en Ukraine ne peut pas
continuer de se faire sans que les
dirigeants russes soient imputables donc
il pourrait y avoir d'autres accusations
si je comprends bien d'autres mandats il
y a un bureau permanent de la Cour
pénale internationale
on se rappelle des femmes qui ont été
violées des gens qui étaient la Cour
pénale internationale enquêter pour
génocide crime de guerre crimes contre
l'humanité et agression et on peut
présumer aujourd'hui qu'elle commence à
partir des preuves dans à peu près tous
ces domaines donc c'est ça les
prochaines étapes finalement on continue
à monter des prix oui on demande au pays
de coopérer vous savez le Pentagone
refusé la semaine dernière de transférer
des informations
au sujet des possibles crimes de guerre
parce qu'il n'est pas signataire du
traité de Rome que mis sur pied la Cour
pénale internationale donc il y a aussi
dans les arrestations dans les mandats
des récitations qu'on émet aujourd'hui
un message pour la communauté
internationale et des nous à bâtir des
dossiers pour éventuellement pouvoir
faire payer ceux qui sont responsables
des crimes de guerre le moral teresco
merci beaucoup au revoir au revoir